hey guys how's it going so today we're
unboxing something while I'm unboxing
knives with another knife if you're new
here you guys might not know that I have
like a small obsession with knives I
really like them and I just want to say
we should be very careful with limes
because they are not a toy you should
not play with them in manners that you
may cut yourself because they are very
dangerous so now is that disclaimers
over we're gonna unbox some knives that
I'm going to be using for future
unboxings and I thought why not do an
unboxing of unboxing knives that sort of
like an unboxing inception are you ready
I don't remember what I ordered
this of course you're ready you may be
surprised with some of my selections I
may be surprised
put some Allies election oh boy let's
just double now so should we start big
or should we start small it was a lot
smaller online to be there that
sometimes happens look at this clear
brush cut branches chop roots let's
start small I got this one recently -
its super cool it's the US Army snow
camel beautiful I don't remember what
this one is I feel like I'm playing csgo
and I'm I'm getting cool knives I don't
even play csgo okay this is kind of
stupid actually it's got a spider and a
spider web on it I will say the colors
are quite nice and I can definitely do
some damage to a box it's like almost
holographic I'm not sure if I'm into the
spider decoration but other than that I
love the colors I'll see how I'll cut
[Music]
hmm I mean it cut that tape quite nicely
smooth like the butter this is a gator
Bowie
this is going to really elevate my
cooking episode significantly not only
cooking when I'm boxing I can definitely
clear some brush with us too
but this is real this isn't plastic by
the way this is like a real life yes
that's real that's real sharp safety
first I need to get a belt first
looks like felt good yeah it looks great
what's cool this is fashion you should
go to prom ah that's probably illegal
yeah yeah this is for clearing brush do
I need a license for this one machete it
has my first machete I've never had one
before they also include the sheath yeah
my dad's going to love it I should get
someone to even be super into it I mean
this is honestly it's elevating my
unboxing dollar like I said honest
that's my Hashem oh hey you've not here
the hatched yet this is the hot ticket
item this Christmas Hashem I think it's
trying but if the battery's dead super
hot oh hey maybe I'll hatch my hockey
mole with my machete okay I got to get
this out of here oh my gosh does anybody
oh it's a children's right Oh yep okay
well now that I went to sleep I gotta
get my sheep out I guess let's take it
outside real close sink shall we okay
cool mommy's got work to do
let me find a branch that needs trip
[Music]
I feel bad I don't want to hurt him
where I'm stopped falling down
what's going on here well clicking
they're doing like some gymnastic stuff
it's really going
I'm so confused look at that huh maybe I
have their problems attend to this like
I will put my knife back in here I guess
it's more than a knife see you like got
to be super careful with this one
and I think maybe landscaping is not
something that I'm cut out for hey do
you think it could be ready just
something you think is cool hi guys well
thanks for watching I look forward to
unboxing some careful honey here take
that chapstick and run mm-hmm
I look forward to unboxing some fun
things in the future with my new knives
and you may also see this in the kitchen
so stay tuned I'll see you guys soon
let me know if there's anything else
you'd like to see me unbox in the future
leave in the comments below and I'll see
you later this body
[Music]